militaire l'un des objectifs de
l'Ukraine c'est de pouvoir couper en
deux cette zone contrôlée par les rues
celles se situe donc au sud du pays
analyse pour France 24 bâtisse falvoses
chroniqueur international ici
à plusieurs axes sont peut-être le voir
derrière moi sur lequel sur lesquels se
font donc cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne voilà la carte arrive tout
de suite là en fait en gros ce dont on
parle là de depuis maintenant quelques
jours et c'est reconquêtes de village ça
va d'une zone qui fait environ 100 150
km qui s'étendent l'est donc des aporer
déjà
qui est un village qui a été revendiqué
par les Ukrainiens comme étant repris et
ces dernières heures jusqu'à Donetsk
après à peu près d'honnête voilà avec
une intensification particulière ici
derrière moi vous le voyez au dessus au
nord en fait de star homélie niska c'est
très important il y a beaucoup de
combats ici pourquoi parce qu'en fait
cette zone elle est l'une des plus
proches de la mer d'Azov que vous voyez
derrière moi et en gros ce que veulent
effectivement pour répondre à votre
question dans un monde idéal une partie
de la stratégie ukrainienne c'est de
pouvoir couper en deux cette continuité
territoriale qui existe donc entre la
Russie à l'est et la Crimée ici et en
sachant que si on coupe cette continuité
territoriale déjà on a un accès à la mer
d'Azov mais en plus ça permet d'éviter
l'approvisionnement en fait des troupes
russes qui sont basés ici en Crimée mais
également dans la région de Helson et
donc ça serait un vrai handicap pour la
Russie ça permettrait également à
l'Ukraine de ce présenter en position de
force dans l'optique d'éventuelles
négociations même si on est encore très
loin de l'issue de cette guerre et puis
ça permettrait aussi peut-être d'assurer
une continuité avec la ville de Mario
Paul qui on sait et au combien
symbolique puisqu'elle est tombée après
des mois de résistance HRD de la
désukrainien en mai 2022 donc voilà
récupérer une partie de la mer d'Azov ou
un accès à la mer d'azoff couper les
lignes russes en deux ça fait partie des
stratégies et les plus importantes de la
part de l'Ukraine et je précise
également vous le voyez là ici honoré
sur la carte il y a la ville de barmut
il est également quelques grignotages de
terrain de la part de l'armée
ukrainienne mais là on parle de quelques
centaines de mètres sur les flancs de la
ville de Barbusse qui ne changent pas
grand chose à la situation et bien sûr
la région de zapporija ou trois villages
ont été revendiqués comme étant repris
par l'armée ukrainienne ces dernières
heures mais encore une fois restons très
prudents c'est une guerre dans laquelle
le silence est roi à côté Ukrainiens
avec une part aussi de désinformation il
faut le dire et puis les villages
peuvent passer très facilement d'un camp
à l'autre donc pour l'instant voilà
gardons une certaine prudence alors vous
avez évoqué justement c'est ces gains
Ukrainiens c'est important de de les
relativiser aujourd'hui un Baptiste
d'autant que les lignes de défense russe
il faut le dire elle s'étale sur
plusieurs lignes oui alors voilà selon
déjà la mise de la défense adjointe
russe ce sont 90 km² seulement qui ont
été récupérés depuis une semaine là
c'est un confetti sur les 90 000 km² qui
sont encore à peu près occupés par
Moscou et même si l'armée ukrainienne
effectivement parvient à créer des
brèches dans ses premières lignes de
défense il y en a plusieurs autres qui
les attendent des tranchées des mines
des blocs de béton ce qu'on appelle vous
savez les dents de dragons qui sont ces
blocs de béton de forme pyramidale qui
sont censés arrêter ou en tout cas
limiter la progression des charges
ukrainiens et donc à chaque fois qu'une
brèche est faite dans la défense ruse il
faut aussi employer des moyens du génie
côté ukrainien il faut déminer il faut
construire des passerelles il faut faire
appel à des bulldozers ça prend
énormément de temps ça demande des
moyens il faut du matériel pour cela
enfin c'est pas parce qu'un village est
libéré on le disait à l'instant qu'il ne
peut rien se passer d'autre il peut y
avoir aussi des informateurs qui
travaillent pour les Russes et qui
restent au sein de ces villages donc
tout cela confirme en fait le fait qu'il
faudra attendre au minimum des semaines
voire des mois pour juger de
l'efficacité ou pas de cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne